minchia che allegri ha annotato adesso
che c'è un tizio giu
e dietro le transenne c1 con gli occhi
bianchi che bello
mi piace questo gioco in uk per tutti
ragazzi benvenute questo video sono
famiglie io ci siamo su klose ora i
saluti cliente a d 4d 32 you grow bb
phil veri steve are only be a firma
ospitò il feedback norma en ciel der
letzte 2057 quindi un gioco futurista
poi si scopre che però nel 2050 7 va
ancora di moda roba tipo e quindi
vorresti travasati le patate descritto
continuo a io posso chiudere i miei
occhi che bello ti fanno male gli occhi
blink formieri chiudi gli occhi tre
volte per me ok 2 è un caso che mi sia
arrivato un messaggio così no ma io cosa
devo fare qua esattamente col tasto
sinistro chiudo gli occhi su successo
sipro state calmi tutti vi prego
cos'è starò buongiorno che bello allegro
cosa vi serve chiudere gli occhi in un
orlo spiegano
perfetto chiudo gli occhi non ho capito
facility a stable salve usa molti bear
cavalca buongiorno non me l'aspettavo
mai all'inizio pensavo ci fosse sei un
po di coccole all'inizio giorni close
your eyes michael in campagna amica
classi e colin che fai questi cosi se ti
mando delle madonne durante il video
fortunatamente non ne capirai perché
parlo italiano ci sono scuse che puoi
fare solo con gli occhi chiusi che bello
simpatico ha delle cose che vedi proprio
solo ad occhi chiusi e sei bello quindi
è questa che questa l'utilità di
chiudere gli occhi il suo gioco non vedi
delle robe se non ti degli occhi capito
tipo quando c'è un buco affetto da 96
alta quanto un cane per passarvi qua o
alto non so se è un maschio né femmina
protagonista
non ho la flashlight la torcia non ce
l'ho
dove esattamente stiamo andando qualcuno
spiega messo sei scritto c'è qualcuno di
là non entro più tanto in quella porta
di mango di quel gol degli ospiti al
changing live for 138 anni
864 scommetto che devo andare alla porta
264 no il codice accessori ed ha
funzionato ho provato non funziona tutto
c'è la switch
ma cosa tra l'altro sul tuo televisore
funzionerà da dio cioè veramente non so
pensato qualcuno mi spieghi a no quello
con lo chiamava il 234 vediamo a ecco
perché una quella dovevo metterla con
gli occhi aperti perfetto cos'è che
chiamo a si è aperta la porta di prima
che bello tosto a casino bertone lella
switch e non la usiamo
peccato perché mi interessava
[Musica]
pericolo alto voltaggio altro formaggio
niente non possiamo fare negli horror
non si apre mai niente qui si aprono
tutte le porte incredibile bravo colin
hai fatto le porte che si aprono busca
and kill
se sei attaccato da un hulk copriti gli
occhi e con attenzione cammina
all'uscita più vicina
ti chiami osc avete credo delle orme con
gli occhi chiusi va bene quindi se io
incontro humus che sarebbe un husky solo
un po più grosso devi chiudere gli occhi
andare all'uscita più vicino va bene
perché continua a non vedere niente ad
occhi aperti
adesso sono al contrario le orme va bene
capisco colin cosa stai cercando di
dirmi in questo work a vacca che brutto
era era era un husky quello perfetto
bene è stato carino il primo incontro
con maschi cioè nel senso non l'ho visto
grazie a dio
chiude a porta grazie ma tolentino o
un'arma incredibile posso usarla per
tirare in testa ad un autobus che
berlusca a ragazzi seriamente cosa me ne
faccio di una sega l'ho capito siamo ben
scala gigante a posso tagliare la catena
si
e stato il bus che se sta roba qua
[Musica]
chiarissimo ma colin maniche funghi ti
sei fatto prima di fare il suo gioco ma
dopo quanta polvere o creato facendo
cadere quella roba lì è la madonna al
centro della terra è accaduto non
sfruttarmi dentro posso anche entrarci
entrare lì dentro significava farc
lasciare il gioco fa una piega
continua ad altro mi ecco il tasso con
filmami e mi fa andare oltre quel punto
cioè colin veramente un drogato che mi
ha cacciato il gioco lo riaperto è stato
puro
una volta che brutto si vabbè vabbè
occhi chiusi e pedalare tv don matteo
la donna che brutta roba sappiamo se
qualcosa mi sta seguendo ancora no non
lo sappiamo ma non voglio neanche
scoprirono avanti
ecco ora non avevo dubbi
devo seguire il filo il corso con le
orme di nuovo look cosa che guardo cos'è
che qualche cerchiato qui look up
guarda su ma va a cagare va quindi
faccio una botola linea permesso qua è
entrato ovunque c'è un amica in nano
benissimo c'è un cadavere lo lascio lì
poi c'è qualcosa una tessera
ok torniamo indietro cos'è che sia
aperto di da ho sentito e cosa aprirsi
mi aspettavo il jobs che da un momento
all'altro non è successo via veloce
quindi amy veramente che non c'è nessuno
stai dicendo questo c'è però la porta
riaperta tra l'altro che di quella porta
va l'altro
guarda non facciamo domande che meglio
tirare va via via dalle palle subito
cosa ha tirato la leva quindi la celi
energia adesso che siamo riusciti a fare
un qualcosa di decente o balance
facciamo veloci grazie
oggi su buon dio via via via via via via
via via via via via frida premo si
chiusa brutto gioco e va beh
ma do non ci credo no vabbè nostro male
quanto brutto ma brutto vado a forte o
no fermi devo veramente andare
nell'ascensore così porca vacca la faida
odio grazie ma chi è chiaro che cosa
cosa sta 1 un giorgia un milione
animatronic che mi fissa che bello
giorno 1 11 ore 56 minuti senza secondi
va bene perfetto ho messo fai entrare
suoi ragazzi lo interrompo qua perché
dura un pochettino questo horror
l'impresa tutt ora se poco matura un po
quindi farò un altro episodio per essere
un indie horror
era da un po che non ne vedevo di usi
carini cioè non è scontato per niente
veramente figo mi sta piacendo un botto
ragazzi vi sia piaciuto coach conte mi
piace anche ha venduto una descrizione
so se questi schiavi e non ci vediamo la
possibilità ai ragazzi
[Musica]